This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. No matter how hard we try to avoid them, conflicts are everywhere. Kids cobble over breakfast at the kitchen table. Colleagues bigger in a team meeting. Nations clash across the globe. For many of us, our first impulse when it comes to conflict is to ask, how can I shut it down? How can I resolve it? This impulse makes sense. Conflict is uncomfortable and unpleasant.
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. No matter how hard we try to avoid them, conflicts are everywhere. Kids cobble over breakfast at the kitchen table. Colleagues bigger in a team meeting. Nations clash across the globe. For many of us, our first impulse when it comes to conflict is to ask, how can I shut it down? How can I resolve it? This impulse makes sense. Conflict is uncomfortable and unpleasant.|||这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。无论我们如何努力避免，冲突无处不在。孩子们在餐桌旁为早餐争执不休。同事们在团队会议上争吵。世界各地的国家发生冲突。对我们许多人来说，面对冲突时的第一冲动就是问：我该如何平息它？我该如何解决它？这种冲动是有道理的。冲突是令人不舒服且不愉快的。
It produces hurt and animosity. It can destroy relationships. But sometimes, the roots of antagonism and anger are so deeply entrenched that avoiding conflict isn't possible and trying to reach a happy place of agreement and love isn't realistic. holistic. Increasingly, psychological research is taking a different approach to discord, with profound implications for disputes big and small. This week on Hidden Brain, we kick off a series that we are calling relationships 2.0. Today, what if we set aside the goal of eliminating conflict and instead ask, how can we do conflict better? Think back to the last time you found yourself in an argument with someone. It might have been over something trivial, like a parking spot on a crowded street.
It produces hurt and animosity. It can destroy relationships. But sometimes, the roots of antagonism and anger are so deeply entrenched that avoiding conflict isn't possible and trying to reach a happy place of agreement and love isn't realistic. holistic. Increasingly, psychological research is taking a different approach to discord, with profound implications for disputes big and small. This week on Hidden Brain, we kick off a series that we are calling relationships 2.0. Today, what if we set aside the goal of eliminating conflict and instead ask, how can we do conflict better? Think back to the last time you found yourself in an argument with someone. It might have been over something trivial, like a parking spot on a crowded street.|||它会产生伤害和敌意。它会破坏人际关系。但有时，对立和愤怒的根源根深蒂固，以至于避免冲突是不可能的，而试图达到达成共识和爱的美好境界也是不切实际的。整体的。越来越多的心理学研究正在对不和采取不同的方法，这对大大小小的争端都有深远的影响。本周的Hidden Brain节目中，我们开启了一个名为“关系2.0”的系列节目。今天，如果我们抛开消除冲突的目标，转而问：我们怎样才能更好地处理冲突？回想一下你上次和别人争吵的时候。可能是一些微不足道的事情，比如拥挤街道上的一个停车位。
Or it might have been serious, like the best path forward for a company or a marriage. Unless you are a very special human being, you likely found yourself getting hot under the collar. You may have felt the other side was being unreasonable, perhaps deliberately so. At Harvard University, psychologists Julia Minson studies the psychology of disagreement. In recent years, she has developed some surprisingly simple but powerful techniques to help people trapped in conflict get unstuck. Julia Minson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me.
Or it might have been serious, like the best path forward for a company or a marriage. Unless you are a very special human being, you likely found yourself getting hot under the collar. You may have felt the other side was being unreasonable, perhaps deliberately so. At Harvard University, psychologists Julia Minson studies the psychology of disagreement. In recent years, she has developed some surprisingly simple but powerful techniques to help people trapped in conflict get unstuck. Julia Minson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me.|||或者可能是一件严肃的事情，比如公司或婚姻的最佳发展道路。除非你是一个非常特别的人，否则你可能会发现自己当时有些火冒三丈。你可能觉得对方很不讲理，也许是故意的。在哈佛大学，心理学家朱莉娅·明森研究的是分歧心理学。近年来，她开发了一些出奇简单但功能强大的技巧，来帮助陷入冲突的人们摆脱困境。朱莉娅·明森，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我。
Julia, I want to take you back to some of your earliest observations about conflict and they took place while you were ballroom dancing, especially when you observed what happened between dancers off stage. When and where was this and what did you observe? So I spent most of my teens and early 20s ballroom dancing, and you just see what happens behind the scenes. And what does happen behind the scenes?
Julia, I want to take you back to some of your earliest observations about conflict and they took place while you were ballroom dancing, especially when you observed what happened between dancers off stage. When and where was this and what did you observe? So I spent most of my teens and early 20s ballroom dancing, and you just see what happens behind the scenes. And what does happen behind the scenes?|||朱莉娅，我想带你回到你对冲突最早的一些观察中，它们发生在你跳交谊舞的时候，特别是当你观察到舞者在台下发生的事情时。这是什么时候、在哪里发生的，你观察到了什么？我在十几岁和二十出头的大部分时间里都在跳交谊舞，你就能看到幕后发生的事情。幕后究竟发生了什么？
Well, what happens behind the scenes is people are practicing and looking like they're fabulously in love. And then the you know, the music stops and they break into an argument about, well, you know, you were too fast or you were too slow or you were leaning or you were not leaning enough. You know, and of course, the other person then doesn't agree with the first person's characterization of what really happened and off they go. So I understand you had a recurrent conflict with your own dance partner, Ryan.
Well, what happens behind the scenes is people are practicing and looking like they're fabulously in love. And then the you know, the music stops and they break into an argument about, well, you know, you were too fast or you were too slow or you were leaning or you were not leaning enough. You know, and of course, the other person then doesn't agree with the first person's characterization of what really happened and off they go. So I understand you had a recurrent conflict with your own dance partner, Ryan.|||嗯，幕后发生的事情是，人们在练习时看起来像是深爱着对方。然后，你知道的，音乐停了，他们就开始争吵，比如，“你知道的，你太快了，或者你太慢了，或者你倾斜了，或者你倾斜得不够。”你知道的，当然，另一个人随后不同意第一个人对实际发生事情的描述，于是他们就吵了起来。据我了解，你和你自己的舞伴瑞安有过经常性的冲突。
At the time he was your boyfriend, he's now your husband. What was that conflict about Julia? You know, so the conflict was something doesn't work, doesn't feel right in the dancing. And you're looking to diagnose the cause and the cause is always the other person. And I started dancing much younger than he did, but he is just a more talented dancer. So between the two of us, I was more knowledgeable, and he was just better.
At the time he was your boyfriend, he's now your husband. What was that conflict about Julia? You know, so the conflict was something doesn't work, doesn't feel right in the dancing. And you're looking to diagnose the cause and the cause is always the other person. And I started dancing much younger than he did, but he is just a more talented dancer. So between the two of us, I was more knowledgeable, and he was just better.|||当时他是你的男朋友，现在他是你的丈夫。朱莉娅，那场冲突是关于什么的？你知道的，冲突在于跳舞时有些东西行不通，感觉不对。你试图诊断原因，而原因总是另一个人。我开始跳舞的时间比他早得多，但他是一个更有天赋的舞者。所以在我们两个之间，我懂得更多，而他就是跳得更好。
And we are not dig screamers. We are more the silent brooders. But we've certainly had times where we stop speaking while we're dancing, but we're preparing for an important competition, so you still have to practice. So you're glaring at each other, not talking to each other, but you're still dancing together. So when you go to graduate school at Stanford University you started working with the great psychologist Lee Roths and and one topic he studied was something called
And we are not dig screamers. We are more the silent brooders. But we've certainly had times where we stop speaking while we're dancing, but we're preparing for an important competition, so you still have to practice. So you're glaring at each other, not talking to each other, but you're still dancing together. So when you go to graduate school at Stanford University you started working with the great psychologist Lee Roths and and one topic he studied was something called|||我们不是那种大喊大叫的人。我们更倾向于默默生闷气的那种。但我们确实有过在跳舞时停止说话的时候，不过我们在为一场重要的比赛做准备，所以你还是得练习。所以你们互相怒视，不跟对方说话，但你们仍然在一起跳舞。因此，当你去斯坦福大学读研究生时，你开始与伟大的心理学家李·罗斯合作，他研究的一个课题被称为
naive realism. We've talked about naive realism on the show before but can you explain what it is and what it predicts happens to people who find themselves in conflict? I think of naive realism as one of the most important ideas on social psychology, and it's basically the idea that people of reality and how things are and how things ought to be are realistic, right? So what I perceive is what's sort of really out there. And it's an idea that works just fine when we talk about our physical perceptions, right? So if I think something is a solid object,
naive realism. We've talked about naive realism on the show before but can you explain what it is and what it predicts happens to people who find themselves in conflict? I think of naive realism as one of the most important ideas on social psychology, and it's basically the idea that people of reality and how things are and how things ought to be are realistic, right? So what I perceive is what's sort of really out there. And it's an idea that works just fine when we talk about our physical perceptions, right? So if I think something is a solid object,|||朴素实在论。我们以前在节目中讨论过朴素实在论，但你能解释一下它是什么，以及它预测陷入冲突的人们会发生什么吗？我认为朴素实在论是社会心理学最重要的思想之一，它基本上是指人们对现实、事物现状以及事物应该如何的看法是现实的，对吧？所以我感知到的就是某种程度上真正存在的东西。当我们谈论我们的物理感知时，这个想法运作得很好，对吧？所以如果我认为某物是一个实体对象，
then I should treat it as such and not walk into it. But then people apply the same conviction to social reality, which is generally really, really messy and often, hotly contested. So you take topics where, you know, where reasonable people disagree and see things very, very differently. And yet, both sides still think that they have an accurate conceptualization of how reality really is, right? Like I basically get it, I see how things really are.
then I should treat it as such and not walk into it. But then people apply the same conviction to social reality, which is generally really, really messy and often, hotly contested. So you take topics where, you know, where reasonable people disagree and see things very, very differently. And yet, both sides still think that they have an accurate conceptualization of how reality really is, right? Like I basically get it, I see how things really are.|||那么我应该把它当作实体对待，而不是撞上去。但随后人们将同样的信念应用于社会现实，而社会现实通常非常非常混乱，而且往往存在激烈的争议。所以你拿一些话题来说，你知道的，理智的人意见不一，对事物的看法截然不同。然而，双方仍然认为他们对现实的真实情况有准确的概念，对吧？就像我基本明白了，我看到了事物的本来面目。
And what people sort of forget is that what I see isn't exactly what's out there, it's what my brain allows me to see. So apply for me, if you will. The idea of naive realism to the disagreement that you would have with Ryan offstage before you would go onstage for your ballroom dancing sessions. What would go through your mind and what would go through his mind that made each of you think the way
And what people sort of forget is that what I see isn't exactly what's out there, it's what my brain allows me to see. So apply for me, if you will. The idea of naive realism to the disagreement that you would have with Ryan offstage before you would go onstage for your ballroom dancing sessions. What would go through your mind and what would go through his mind that made each of you think the way|||而人们有点忘记的是，我看到的并不完全是外面的东西，而是我的大脑允许我看到的东西。所以，如果你愿意的话，请为我应用一下。将朴素实在论的观点应用于你和瑞安在你的交谊舞上台之前在台下产生的意见分歧。你的脑海里会闪过什么，他的脑海里又会闪过什么，让你们每个人都认为
that I'm seeing the situation is the correct way to see the situation. One thing that's really strange about ballroom dancing is that when you're dancing, you are in fact physically facing each other, which means you are literally looking at the world from opposite directions. Right? So as you're sort of going around the room and there might be a mirror on the wall, when you see that mirror, by definition, it means that your partner's back is to the mirror and your partner cannot see it.
that I'm seeing the situation is the correct way to see the situation. One thing that's really strange about ballroom dancing is that when you're dancing, you are in fact physically facing each other, which means you are literally looking at the world from opposite directions. Right? So as you're sort of going around the room and there might be a mirror on the wall, when you see that mirror, by definition, it means that your partner's back is to the mirror and your partner cannot see it.|||我看到这种情况的方式才是看待这种情况的正确方式。交谊舞有一个非常奇怪的地方，那就是当你跳舞时，你们实际上是身体面对面站着的，这意味着你们实际上是从相反的方向看世界。对吧？所以当你绕着房间转时，墙上可能有一面镜子，当你看到那面镜子时，根据定义，这意味着你舞伴的背对着镜子，你的舞伴看不到它。
So 100% of the time you're actually making decisions about what looks right and what doesn't look right based on different information. But I think, you know, the problem sort of goes deeper than that, which is that whenever you disagree, and this was very much part of Lyros' theory, you have to make what he called attributions for disagreement. You have to explain to yourself why is it that we disagree. And it's basically a story you make up in your own mind about, you know, what is the cause of this disagreement. And the simplest version is we disagree because
So 100% of the time you're actually making decisions about what looks right and what doesn't look right based on different information. But I think, you know, the problem sort of goes deeper than that, which is that whenever you disagree, and this was very much part of Lyros' theory, you have to make what he called attributions for disagreement. You have to explain to yourself why is it that we disagree. And it's basically a story you make up in your own mind about, you, what is the cause of this disagreement. And the simplest version is we disagree because|||所以在100%的时间里，你实际上是根据不同的信息来决定什么看起来正确，什么看起来不正确的。但我认为，你知道，问题有点更深层，那就是每当你们意见不合时——这很大程度上是莱罗斯理论的一部分——你都必须对他所谓的意见不合做出归因。你必须向自己解释为什么我们会有分歧。这基本上是你在自己脑海中编造的一个关于“这场分歧的原因是什么”的故事。最简单的版本是，我们有分歧是因为
the other person is wrong. So in mine and Ryan's case, I had a lot more knowledge about the theory. I mean, you don't think of dancing as having theory, but it does because it's a lot of physics. And he was just better without necessarily being able to explain how he's doing what he is doing. And so when we disagreed, both of us had good reason to believe that we were right, because I knew more, and he would say, well, look, this looks better, and this this feels better and therefore it's right. So you and a grad school classmate, Francis Chen came up with a way to get around the problem of naïve realism or at least you thought it would get around the problem of naïve realism and you based an experiment that you conducted on what scientists know about the bond between
the other person is wrong. So in mine and Ryan's case, I had a lot more knowledge about the theory. I mean, you don't think of dancing as having theory, but it does because it's a lot of physics. And he was just better without necessarily being able to explain how he's doing what he is doing. And so when we disagreed, both of us had good reason to believe that we were right, because I knew more, and he would say, well, look, this looks better, and this this feels better and therefore it's right. So you and a grad school classmate, Francis Chen came up with a way to get around the problem of naïve realism or at least you thought it would get around the problem of naïve realism and you based an experiment that you conducted on what scientists know about the bond between|||另一个人错了。所以在我和瑞安的案例中，我对理论有更多的了解。我的意思是，你不会认为跳舞有什么理论，但它确实有，因为它包含了很多物理学。而他只是跳得更好，却不一定能解释他是如何做到他正在做的事情的。因此，当我们意见不合时，我们两人都有充分的理由相信自己是对的，因为我知道得更多，而他会说：“看，这样看起来更好，这样感觉更好，因此它是对的。”所以你和研究生院的同班同学弗朗西斯·陈想出了一个绕过朴素实在论问题的方法，或者至少你认为它能绕过朴素实在论问题，你根据科学家对以下关系的了解进行了一项实验：
parents and children. Describe for me the study Julia. Yeah, so Francis came into the program very interested in developmental psychology and mothers and babies. And we were both sort of really fascinated with this problem of naivrillism and conflict and disagreement. And she said, you know, eye contact is this really powerful mechanism that people have
parents and children. Describe for me the study Julia. Yeah, so Francis came into the program very interested in developmental psychology and mothers and babies. And we were both sort of really fascinated with this problem of naivrillism and conflict and disagreement. And she said, you know, eye contact is this really powerful mechanism that people have|||父母和孩子。请为我描述一下这项研究，朱莉娅。是的，弗朗西斯进入这个项目时对发展心理学以及母亲和婴儿非常感兴趣。我们俩都对朴素实在论、冲突和分歧这个问题非常着迷。她说，你知道，眼神交流是人们拥有的一种非常强大的机制，
that increases bonding. Right? So, you know, mothers and babies gaze into each other's eyes and it releases the hormone oxytocin, which is sort of the bonding hormone, when people are attracted to each other, they gaze into each other's eyes. So what if we got people to gaze into each other's eyes while they're discussing something that they disagree on, and would that trigger kind of this biological liking that would
that increases bonding. Right? So, you know, mothers and babies gaze into each other's eyes and it releases the hormone oxytocin, which is sort of the bonding hormone, when people are attracted to each other, they gaze into each other's eyes. So what if we got people to gaze into each other's eyes while they're discussing something that they disagree on, and would that trigger kind of this biological liking that would|||它能增加凝聚力。对吧？所以，你知道，母亲和婴儿注视着对方的眼睛，这会释放催产素，这有点像凝聚荷尔蒙；当人们互相吸引时，他们会注视着对方的眼睛。那么，如果我们让人们在讨论他们意见不一的事情时互相注视着对方的眼睛，这会触发那种生物学上的好感吗？
then translate into kind of a more sensible conversation. It made sense. So Julia and Francis ran some experiments to test if maintaining eye contact might reduce disagreement. Well, we found that we were wrong. So that was weird, and it was exactly the opposite of what we had predicted. And people who were asked to make direct eye contact with somebody that they disagreed with actually ended up disagreeing even more
then translate into kind of a more sensible conversation. It made sense. So Julia and Francis ran some experiments to test if maintaining eye contact might reduce disagreement. Well, we found that we were wrong. So that was weird, and it was exactly the opposite of what we had predicted. And people who were asked to make direct eye contact with somebody that they disagreed with actually ended up disagreeing even more|||然后转化为一种更理智的对话。这说得通。因此，朱莉娅和弗朗西斯进行了一些实验，以测试保持眼神交流是否能减少分歧。嗯，我们发现我们错了。这很奇怪，而且这与我们预测的完全相反。那些被要求与意见不合的人进行直接眼神交流的人，最终反而更加不同意对方的观点
than the people who were asked to look at the mouth or sort of let their gaze wander. So I understand that you and France has got together to talk about the results. And this was at your home at the time in Philadelphia, paint me a scene of that conversation, Julia. Yeah, so we were in our home. We had just had dinner and my husband was doing the dishes
than the people who were asked to look at the mouth or sort of let their gaze wander. So I understand that you and France has got together to talk about the results. And this was at your home at the time in Philadelphia, paint me a scene of that conversation, Julia. Yeah, so we were in our home. We had just had dinner and my husband was doing the dishes|||甚至超过了那些被要求看着嘴巴或让目光游离的人。据我所知，你和弗朗西斯聚在一起讨论了结果。当时这发生在你在费城的家里，朱莉娅，请给我描绘一下那场对话的场景。是的，当时我们在家里。我们刚吃完晚饭，我丈夫在洗碗
and we were still sitting there talking about the paper. And I thought we had a really counter intuitive finding, it was exactly the opposite of what we had predicted. And I said, great, we get to write this paper that's going to be really attention grabbing about how eye contact is bad. And Frances really didn't like that framing because she had done a lot of work that showed the opposite and we, you know, we started arguing about it.
and we were still sitting there talking about the paper. And I thought we had a really counter intuitive finding, it was exactly the opposite of what we had predicted. And I said, great, we get to write this paper that's going to be really attention grabbing about how eye contact is bad. And Frances really didn't like that framing because she had done a lot of work that showed the opposite and we, you, we started arguing about it.|||我们仍然坐在那里讨论这篇论文。我认为我们有一个非常违反直觉的发现，这与我们的预测完全相反。我说，太好了，我们可以写一篇非常引人注目的论文，讲述眼神交流是如何不好的。弗朗西斯非常不喜欢这个框架，因为她做了大量的工作来证明相反的观点，然后我们，你知道，我们开始为此争论不休。
And Frances is a very, very sort of reasonable, soft, spoken, mild, manner sort of woman. And she wouldn't budge and I wouldn't budge and I was getting frustrated because, you know, we had this like great result and it was so obvious that my framing was better. And eventually, my husband literally interjected physically between us at the kitchen table with two bowls of ice cream. And he said, come on, settle down, take it easy. I love the fact that unlike most people who get in fights, you looked at what happened with curiosity and you asked if there were clues in the conversation to help you better understand the nature of discord.
And Frances is a very, very sort of reasonable, soft, spoken, mild, manner sort of woman. And she wouldn't budge and I wouldn't budge and I was getting frustrated because, you know, we had this like great result and it was so obvious that my framing was better. And eventually, my husband literally interjected physically between us at the kitchen table with two bowls of ice cream. And he said, come on, settle down, take it easy. I love the fact that unlike most people who get in fights, you looked at what happened with curiosity and you asked if there were clues in the conversation to help you better understand the nature of discord.|||弗朗西斯是一个非常非常通情达理、轻声细语、温文尔雅的女性。她不肯让步，我也不肯让步，我开始感到沮丧，因为，你知道，我们有了这样一个伟大的结果，而且很明显我的框架更好。最终，我丈夫端着两碗冰淇淋，直接走到餐桌旁，插在我们中间。他说：“得了吧，冷静点，放轻松。”我非常喜欢这一点：与大多数争吵的人不同，你带着好奇心看待发生的事情，并询问对话中是否有线索能帮助你更好地理解不和的本质。
I'm wondering if you can tell me what you observed about the difference between disagreements and conflict. I think the question you're asking about disagreement versus conflict is really important. And it's, you know, I think it's really important for organizations in particular because on one hand, we often tell people that like disagreement is good, right? You know, we want to have a team of rivals and we want opposing perspectives and everybody should have different ideas about things. On the other hand, conflict feels bad. And so, you know, disagreement as I believe X and you believe why? So in other words, I like vanilla, you like chocolate. Yes, absolutely.
I'm wondering if you can tell me what you observed about the difference between disagreements and conflict. I think the question you're asking about disagreement versus conflict is really important. And it's, you know, I think it's really important for organizations in particular because on one hand, we often tell people that like disagreement is good, right? You know, we want to have a team of rivals and we want opposing perspectives and everybody should have different ideas about things. On the other hand, conflict feels bad. And so, you know, disagreement as I believe X and you believe why? So in other words, I like vanilla, you like chocolate. Yes, absolutely.|||我想知道你能否告诉我，你观察到的分歧与冲突之间有什么区别。我认为你问的关于分歧与冲突的问题非常重要。你知道的，我认为这对组织来说尤其重要，因为一方面，我们经常告诉人们，分歧是好的，对吧？你知道，我们想要一个竞争对手团队，我们想要对立的观点，每个人对事物都应该有不同的想法。另一方面，冲突感觉不好。所以，你知道，分歧就像我相信X，而你相信Y？换句话说，我喜欢香草味，你喜欢巧克力味。是的，绝对是这样。
Or I think this candidate will win and you think that candidate will win. And most of the time presumably, I'm okay with you believing X and me believing Y doesn't threaten me for you to be believing one thing while I believe the other. Right. So you can think of lots of disagreements that are actually very enjoyable, right? So people love debating, you know, what the end of a particular TV show really meant, right? Or which sports team should win the Super Bowl, right? So there are some disagreements that aren't just okay, they're actually fun. So what happens when disagreement spiral into conflict? What changes?
Or I think this candidate will win and you think that candidate will win. And most of the time presumably, I'm okay with you believing X and me believing Y doesn't threaten me for you to be believing one thing while I believe the other. Right. So you can think of lots of disagreements that are actually very enjoyable, right? So people love debating, you know, what the end of a particular TV show really meant, right? Or which sports team should win the Super Bowl, right? So there some disagreements that aren't just okay, they're actually fun. So what happens when disagreement spiral into conflict? What changes?|||或者我认为这位候选人会赢，而你认为那位候选人会赢。而且大多数时候想必我都可以接受你相信X，而我相信Y，你相信某事而我相信另一件事并不会对构成威胁。对吧。所以你可以想到很多实际上非常令人愉快的意见分歧，对吧？人们喜欢争论，你知道的，某个电视剧结局的真正含义是什么，对吧？或者哪支运动球队应该赢得超级碗，对吧？所以有些分歧不仅可以接受，而且实际上很有趣。那么，当分歧演变成冲突时会发生什么？什么变了？
Really, when we're talking about regular people in their regular lives, it's conflict about beliefs or conflict about attitudes. And the difference between disagreement and attitude conflict is that I believe X, you believe Y, and I'm not okay with you believing Y. I need to change your Y to be closer to my X. What do you think drives that? Why is it in some cases we are okay with you believing that Team 1 is going to win the Super Bowl. I'm okay with Team 2 winning the Super Bowl,
Really, when we're talking about regular people in their regular lives, it's conflict about beliefs or conflict about attitudes. And the difference between disagreement and attitude conflict is that I believe X, you believe Y, and I'm not okay with you believing Y. I need to change your Y to be closer to my X. What do you think drives that? Why is it in some cases we are okay with you believing that Team 1 is going to win the Super Bowl. I'm okay with Team 2 winning the Super Bowl,|||真的，当我们谈论普通人的日常生活时，这是关于信念的冲突或关于态度的冲突。分歧与态度冲突的区别在于，我相信X，你相信Y，而我不能接受你相信Y。我需要改变你的Y，使其更接近我的X。你认为是什么驱动了这一点？为什么在某些情况下，我们可以接受你相信第一队会赢得超级碗。我可以接受第二队赢得超级碗，
but on other issues I desperately need you to believe what I believe. but on other issues I desperately need you to believe what I believe. So I think there's three things that play into it. The first factor that, of course, matters is, is this an important issue? Is this something that I believe has important consequences? So for example, if you and I disagree about the importance of flossing your teeth, it's not as important as if we disagree about the importance of getting vaccinated against COVID-19. Right? So one, we'll give you cavities.
but on other issues I desperately need you to believe what I believe. but on other issues I desperately need you to believe what I believe. So I think there's three things that play into it. The first factor that, of course, matters is, is this an important issue? Is this something that I believe has important consequences? So for example, if you and I disagree about the importance of flossing your teeth, it's not as important as if we disagree about the importance of getting vaccinated against COVID-19. Right? So one, we'll give you cavities.|||但在其他问题上，我迫切需要你相信我所相信的。但在其他问题上，我迫切需要你相信我所相信的。所以我认为有三件事在起作用。当然，重要的第一个因素是，这是一个重要的问题吗？这是我认为会产生重要后果的事情吗？例如，如果你我不同意使用牙线清洁牙齿的重要性，这并不像我们不同意接种COVID-19疫苗的重要性那样重要。对吧？所以一方面，这会导致你蛀牙。
The other might kill you. There is a big difference in importance. The second one is what we call interdependence. So does your attitude actually affect my outcomes? If we're a couple going out to dinner, and I want Chinese and you want pizza, we're completely interdependent because we have to agree on where we're going.
The other might kill you. There is a big difference in importance. The second one is what we call interdependence. So does your attitude actually affect my outcomes? If we're a couple going out to dinner, and I want Chinese and you want pizza, we're completely interdependent because we have to agree on where we're going.|||另一个可能会要你的命。重要性有很大的不同。第二个是我们所说的相互依赖。那么你的态度真的会影响我的结果吗？如果我们是一对出去吃晚餐的情侣，我想要中餐，而你想要披萨，我们是完全相互依赖的，因为我们必须就去哪里达成一致。
And so now, if you add that up with importance, your preference is on it directly impact me, right? So think about, you know, buying a home in this neighborhood or that neighborhood. It's an important thing and we are stuck together in this house. Right. And what's the third factor? The third factor is what we call evadeshary skew. And basically what that means is, do I believe that the
And so now, if you add that up with importance, your preference is on it directly impact me, right? So think about, you know, buying a home in this neighborhood or that neighborhood. It's an important thing and we are stuck together in this house. Right. And what's the third factor? The third factor is what we call evadeshary skew. And basically what that means is, do I believe that the|||所以现在，如果把这一点和重要性加在一起，你的偏好就会直接影响我，对吧？所以想想看，在这个社区还是那个社区买房子。这是一件很重要的事情，我们被困在这个房子里了。对。第三个因素是什么？第三个因素是我们所说的证据偏见（evadeshary skew）。基本上这意味着，我认为
evidence is overwhelmingly on my side? And so once you end up in a situation where the issue is important, we are interdependent in terms of our actions and beliefs, and both of us believe that there's more evidence on our side than the other side. Then it's very hard to just let the other person keep believing whatever it is they want to. And I'm thinking about you and your colleague Francis as you were sitting at your kitchen table arguing about the results of the paper. Uh-huh. You know, in some ways it meets all three criteria. It does. It's, you know, years of work and we're stuck together because we're co-authors and we both think we have the right answer.
evidence is overwhelmingly on my side? And so once you end up in a situation where the issue is important, we are interdependent in terms of our actions and beliefs, and both of us believe that there's more evidence on our side than the other side. Then it's very hard to just let the other person keep believing whatever it is they want to. And I'm thinking about you and your colleague Francis as you were sitting at your kitchen table arguing about the results of the paper. Uh-huh. You know, in some ways it meets all three criteria. It does. It's, you know, years of work and we're stuck together because we're co-authors and we both think we have the right answer.|||证据完全站在我这边吗？因此，一旦你陷入这样一种境地：问题很重要，我们在行动和信念上相互依存，并且我们双方都认为自己这边的证据比对方多。那么，要让另一个人继续相信他们想相信的任何事情，就非常困难了。我想起了你和你的同事弗朗西斯坐在餐桌旁争论论文结果的情景。嗯哼。你知道，在某些方面，它满足了所有三个标准。确实如此。你知道的，这是多年的工作，我们被困在一起，因为我们是合著者，而且我们都认为我们有正确的答案。
Much as two parties might disagree with each other but still need to coexist, people on different sides of a disagreement often still need to work together. A fighting couple might be raising children together. Israelis and Palestinians might share common ground when it comes to combating climate change. Republicans and Democrats who are at log-aheads on social spending might agree on the importance of imposing sanctions on a rogue nation. When we come back, techniques to keep conflict in one area from spiraling into places where we share common ground. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
Much as two parties might disagree with each other but still need to coexist, people on different sides of a disagreement often still need to work together. A fighting couple might be raising children together. Israelis and Palestinians might share common ground when it comes to combating climate change. Republicans and Democrats who are at log-aheads on social spending might agree on the importance of imposing sanctions on a rogue nation. When we come back, techniques to keep conflict in one area from spiraling into places where we share common ground. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.|||正如两方可能存在分歧但仍需要共存一样，分歧双方的人们通常仍需要合作。吵架的夫妇可能在共同抚养孩子。以色列人和巴勒斯坦人在应对气候变化方面可能有共同点。在社会支出问题上针锋相对的共和党人和民主党人，可能会就对流氓国家实施制裁的重要性达成一致。广告回来后，我们将介绍防止某一领域的冲突蔓延到我们有共同点的地方的技术。您正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Julia Minson is a psychologist at the Harvard Kennedy School of Government. She studies the psychology of disagreement. Many experts in Julia's field of conflict resolution research ways to get people to come to agreement on contentious issues. Julia's research has taken a different tack. She has observed that in many cases, people on different sides of a contentious issue might never change their minds, but they still need to work together
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Julia Minson is a psychologist at the Harvard Kennedy School of Government. She studies the psychology of disagreement. Many experts in Julia's field of conflict resolution research ways to get people to come to agreement on contentious issues. Julia's research has taken a different tack. She has observed that in many cases, people on different sides of a contentious issue might never change their minds, but they still need to work together|||这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。朱莉娅·明森是哈佛大学肯尼迪政府学院的心理学家。她研究分歧心理学。在朱莉娅所在的冲突解决研究领域，许多专家都在研究如何让人们就有争议的问题达成一致的方法。朱莉娅的研究采取了不同的方向。她观察到，在许多情况下，有争议问题不同立场的人可能永远不会改变主意，但他们仍然需要合作
on matters of shared importance. Julia, as we've seen, conflicts have a way of spiraling. Once we jump to the conclusion that people who disagree with us on something are our enemies, it poisons the water on every issue, including areas where agreement is possible. Now you've had a recurring argument with your husband, Ryan is a data analytics expert and he periodically wonders whether he should find a new job. Tell me how these conversations unfold and how they became a source of conflict? Well, so we have been together for a very long time. We have been married for 22 years now. So every few years, we go through sort of a period
on matters of shared importance. Julia, as we've seen, conflicts have a way of spiraling. Once we jump to the conclusion that people who disagree with us on something are our enemies, it poisons the water on every issue, including areas where agreement is possible. Now you've had a recurring argument with your husband, Ryan is a data analytics expert and he periodically wonders whether he should find a new job. Tell me how these conversations unfold and how they became a source of conflict? Well, so we have been together for a very long time. We have been married for 22 years now. So every few years, we go through sort of a period|||处理具有共同重要性的事情。朱莉娅，正如我们所见，冲突往往会不断升级。一旦我们草率得出结论：在某些事情上与我们意见不合的人就是我们的敌人，这就会毒害每一个问题的水质，包括那些有可能达成一致的领域。现在，你和你的丈夫有过一次反复发生的争论，瑞安是一位数据分析专家，他定期想知道自己是否应该找一份新工作。请告诉我这些对话是如何展开的，以及它们是如何成为冲突之源的？嗯，所以我们在一起很长时间了。我们已经结婚22年了。所以每隔几年，我们都会经历一段时间
where he says something like, well, you know, it's been three years since the last time I've gotten promoted. And so for the next few months, just FYI, I'm going to be working really long hours because at my next annual review, I want to jump to the next level. And that all sounds very sensible,
where he says something like, well, you know, it's been three years since the last time I've gotten promoted. And so for the next few months, just FYI, I'm going to be working really long hours because at my next annual review, I want to jump to the next level. And that all sounds very sensible,|||他会说这样的话：“嗯，你知道的，距离我上次晋升已经三年了。所以在接下来的几个月里，顺便告诉大家，我要工作很长时间，因为在我的下一次年度评估中，我想跃升到下一个级别。”这听起来都很明智，
but what that really means is that he's going to work really, really hard. They're not going to recognize it because corporate America is rarely fair. And then he will be frustrated. And then we'll go through another sort of like long drawn out period of him deciding what to do and whether to move somewhere else. And you're describing this in a very calm, level-headed, analytical way. I'm assuming that's the way these conversations actually unfold it.
but what that really means is that he's going to work really, really hard. They're not going to recognize it because corporate America is rarely fair. And then he will be frustrated. And then we'll go through another sort of like long drawn out period of him deciding what to do and whether to move somewhere else. And you're describing this in a very calm, level-headed, analytical way. I'm assuming that's the way these conversations actually unfold it.|||但这真正意味着他将非常非常努力地工作。他们不会认可这一点，因为美国企业界很少是公平的。然后他会感到沮丧。接着，我们会经历另一个漫长而拖沓的时期，由他来决定该做什么以及是否搬到别的地方去。你以一种非常平静、清醒、分析的方式描述这一点。我假设这些对话实际展开时就是这样的。
Well, these conversations unfold like this in my head, whereas, you know, in reality, what happens, right, is that he tells me that he's unhappy in his job, and I tell him what to do. And he says, and I tell him what to do. And he says, don't tell me what to do. And ironically, the longer you're married, the less you feel heard, because nobody's actually listening anymore, because we both think we know what the other person is about to say. He is about to complain about his job.
Well, these conversations unfold like this in my head, whereas, you know, in reality, what happens, right, is that he tells me that he's unhappy in his job, and I tell him what to do. And he says, and I tell him what to do. And he says, don-t tell me what to do. And ironically, the longer you're married, the less you feel heard, because nobody's actually listening anymore, because we both think we know what the other person is about to say. He is about to complain about his job.|||嗯，这些对话在我的脑海里是这样展开的，然而，你知道的，现实中发生的事情是，他告诉我他对工作不满意，而我告诉他该怎么做。他说，而我告诉他该怎么做。他说，别告诉该我怎么做。具有讽刺意味的是，结婚时间越长，你越觉得没有人倾听你的心声，因为实际上已经没有人认真倾听了，因为我们都觉得自己知道对方要说什么。他要抱怨他的工作。
I'm about to tell him to go get another job offer so that he gets promoted at the current job because he has an alternative offer. And then he will tell me to stop meddling in his career. And then I will walk off in a cuff because it's not just his career. It's our whole, it affects the whole family. And you know, I mean, it's tremendously important. You know, my husband's income is the lion's share of the income in our household. And we are completely interdependent because when he says,
I'm about to tell him to go get another job offer so that he gets promoted at the current job because he has an alternative offer. And then he will tell me to stop meddling in his career. And then I will walk off in a cuff because it's not just his career. It's our whole, it affects the whole family. And you know, I mean, it's tremendously important. You know, my husband's income is the lion's share of the income in our household. And we are completely interdependent because when he says,|||我正要告诉他去拿到另一份工作Offer，这样他就能在当前的工作中获得晋升，因为他有一个替代Offer。然后他会让我不要干涉他的职业生涯。接着我会生着闷气走开，因为这不仅仅是他的职业生涯。这是我们的全部，它影响着整个家庭。你知道的，我的意思是，这极其重要。你知道的，我丈夫的收入占我们家庭收入的大头。而且我们完全相互依赖，因为当他说：
I'm going to work much longer hours to get this next promotion. It means that I am now taking care of three kids with less help. And, of course, I teach negotiations. So I think I know how to do this. So I am 100% confident that I'm right. And he says, no, it's my career in my organization. And I know the rules. And I'm 100% confident that I'm right.
I'm going to work much longer hours to get this next promotion. It means that I am now taking care of three kids with less help. And, of course, I teach negotiations. So I think I know how to do this. So I am 100% confident that I'm right. And he says, no, it's my career in my organization. And I know the rules. And I'm 100% confident that I'm right.|||“为了获得下一次晋升，我要工作更长时间。”这意味着我现在要在更少帮助的情况下照顾三个孩子。而且，当然，我教的是谈判。所以我想我知道该怎么做。所以我百分之百确信我是对的。而他说：“不，这是我在我的组织中的职业生涯。我知道规则。而且我百分之百确信我是对的。”
Now, you decided to try something with Ryan that you were learning from your research, but in order to get to that, after you're somewhat fall start with that eye contact study, you started working on a technique that you call conversational receptiveness. What is conversational receptiveness? So, conversational receptiveness is the use of words and phrases to demonstrate to your counterpart that you're engaged with their point of view. Quite often when we give people advice about conflict
Now, you decided to try something with Ryan that you were learning from your research, but in order to get to that, after you're somewhat fall start with that eye contact study, you started working on a technique that you call conversational receptiveness. What is conversational receptiveness? So, conversational receptiveness is the use of words and phrases to demonstrate to your counterpart that you're engaged with their point of view. Quite often when we give people advice about conflict|||现在，你决定在瑞安身上尝试一些你从研究中学到的东西，但在那之前，在你与那个眼神交流研究经历了一些不太顺利的开端之后，你开始研究一种你称之为“对话接受度”的技巧。什么是对话接受度？因此，对话接受度是指使用词语和短语向对方表明你正在关注他们的观点。通常，当我们向人们提供有关冲突的建议时
and how they should handle conflict, we tell them try to be more empathetic, try to take the other person's perspective, try to exercise the other person's perspective, right? Try to exercise intellectual humility. And what we found was that their counterpart has no idea that they're doing any of that. It's not transparent, and because it's not transparent,
and how they should handle conflict, we tell them try to be more empathetic, try to take the other person's perspective, try to exercise the other person's perspective, right? Try to exercise intellectual humility. And what we found was that their counterpart has no idea that they're doing any of that. It's not transparent, and because it's not transparent,|||以及他们应该如何处理冲突时，我们会告诉他们尽量多一点同理心，尝试站在对方的角度考虑问题，尝试践行对方的观点，对吧？尝试保持求知谦逊。而我们发现的是，对方根本不知道他们在做这些。它是不透明的，正因为它是不透明的，
it has no effect on the conflict. And so conversational receptiveness is basically predicated on the idea that we need to demonstrate to people that were engaged with their point of view in a way that's visible and very easily recognizable to counterparts because you can't get credit for things in your head. Julia discovered through her research that there are four specific techniques
it has no effect on the conflict. And so conversational receptiveness is basically predicated on the idea that we need to demonstrate to people that were engaged with their point of view in a way that's visible and very easily recognizable to counterparts because you can't get credit for things in your head. Julia discovered through her research that there are four specific techniques|||它对冲突没有任何影响。因此，对话接受度基本上建立在这样一个理念之上：我们需要以一种对对方来说清晰可见且极易识别的方式向人们表明，我们正在关注他们的观点，因为你不能因为你脑子里的想法而获得认可。朱莉娅通过研究发现有四种具体的技术
that communicate conversational receptiveness. And they make a nice acronym. The acronym is here, lesson I hear you, the age stands for hedging. So it's saying things like perhaps or some times or maybe. The e stands for emphasizing agreement. So I might say, I agree that the last couple years have been really hard on people. Or we both think that it's really important to make schools say for our kids. The A stands for acknowledgement. So it's essentially using some of your own air time to
that communicate conversational receptiveness. And they make a nice acronym. The acronym is here, lesson I hear you, the age stands for hedging. So it's saying things like perhaps or some times or maybe. The e stands for emphasizing agreement. So I might say, I agree that the last couple years have been really hard on people. Or we both think that it's really important to make schools say for our kids. The A stands for acknowledgement. So it's essentially using some of your own air time to|||传达对话接受度。它们组成了一个很好的缩写词。这个缩写词是here（听着），吸取教训我听到你了，年龄（age）代表对冲（hedging）。所以它说的是诸如“也许”、“有时”或“可能”之类的话。e代表强调一致。所以我可能会说：“我同意过去几年对人们来说确实很艰难。”或者“我们都认为让学校对我们的孩子安全真的很重要。”A代表承认。所以它本质上是利用你自己的谈话时间来
restate your counterparts position. And then the R stands for reframing to the positive. So you can basically say the exact same idea using positive words instead of negative terms, right? You might say, you know, instead of saying, I hated when people interrupt me, you might say, I really love it when people let me finish. Julia has used this four-step process, hedging, emphasizing areas of agreement, acknowledging the other person's perspective, and reframing to the positive to train groups of people in the practice of conversational receptiveness. I asked her to describe what happens when people employ these techniques. So it's really interesting. There is work going back to the 1960s
restate your counterparts position. And then the R stands for reframing to the positive. So you can basically say the exact same idea using positive words instead of negative terms, right? You might say, you know, instead of saying, I hated when people interrupt me, you might say, I really love it when people let me finish. Julia has used this four-step process, hedging, emphasizing areas of agreement, acknowledging the other person's perspective, and reframing to the positive to train groups of people in the practice of conversational receptiveness. I asked her to describe what happens when people employ these techniques. So it's really interesting. There is work going back to the 1960s|||重申你对方的立场。然后R代表重新构建为积极的。所以你基本上可以用积极的词汇而不是消极的词汇来表达完全相同的想法，对吧？你可能会说，你知道的，与其说“我讨厌别人打断我”，不如说“我真的很喜欢别人让我把话说完”。朱莉娅利用这四个步骤的过程——对冲、强调一致领域、承认对方的观点以及重新构建为积极的——来培训群体进行对话接受度的练习。我请她描述当人们采用这些技术时会发生什么。所以这真的很有趣。可以追溯到20世纪60年代的工作
that basically says people love feeling heard. And that's essentially what conversational receptiveness does. Is it makes people feel like their counterpart is really engaging with them? And so as a consequence, they think of those counterparts as more trustworthy. They think of them as being more objective. They think they have better professional judgment.
that basically says people love feeling heard. And that's essentially what conversational receptiveness does. Is it makes people feel like their counterpart is really engaging with them? And so as a consequence, they think of those counterparts as more trustworthy. They think of them as being more objective. They think they have better professional judgment.|||基本上是说人们喜欢被倾听的感觉。这本质上就是对话接受度所做的事情。它是让人们觉得对方真的在与他们互动吗？因此，他们认为这些对方更值得信赖。他们认为他们更客观。他们认为他们有更好的职业判断力。
If this is a professional situation, they're more willing to talk to this person about other issues. So basically you get a lot of positive interpersonal benefits from essentially saying the same thing, but saying it in a way that acknowledges your partner's point of view. And I understand that there are elements of conversation receptiveness that in some ways are contagious, that in some ways you're demonstrating it from to your partner as well to demonstrate some of it? Yes, and the thing that's very interesting
If this is a professional situation, they're more willing to talk to this person about other issues. So basically you get a lot of positive interpersonal benefits from essentially saying the same thing, but saying it in a way that acknowledges your partner's point of view. And I understand that there are elements of conversation receptiveness that in some ways are contagious, that in some ways you're demonstrating it from to your partner as well to demonstrate some of it? Yes, and the thing that's very interesting|||如果这是一个职业环境，他们更愿意与这个人讨论其他问题。所以基本上，你从本质上说同样的事情中获得了很多积极的人际交往益处，但表达方式要承认你伴侣的观点。据我了解，对话接受度的某些元素在某些方面是具有传染性的，在某些方面你也在向你的伴侣展示它，以展示其中的一些部分？是的，非常有趣的一点是
about conversational receptiveness is that we've done studies where we train one person to be conversational or receptive, right? Let's say person A, and then person B responds to person A, and not only is it the case that the more receptive A is, the more receptive B is, but it also seems that B is using other
about conversational receptiveness is that we've done studies where we train one person to be conversational or receptive, right? Let's say person A, and then person B responds to person A, and not only is it the case that the more receptive A is, the more receptive B is, but it also seems that B is using other|||关于对话接受度，我们做过这样的研究：我们训练一个人变得善于交谈或具有接受度，对吧？比方说A，然后B回应A，不仅A越具有接受度，B就越具有接受度，而且似乎B也在使用其他
aspects of conversational receptiveness. So they're picking up kind of like the whole style. They're not just directly copying the words that were said to them. A lot of the work on conversation receptiveness is focused on the value of asking questions. And I think most people don't think about the difference between asking questions versus making statements.
aspects of conversational receptiveness. So they're picking up kind of like the whole style. They're not just directly copying the words that were said to them. A lot of the work on conversation receptiveness is focused on the value of asking questions. And I think most people don't think about the difference between asking questions versus making statements.|||对话接受度的各个方面。所以他们有点像在学习整个风格。他们不仅仅是直接复制对他们说的话。关于对话接受度的大量工作都集中在提问的价值上。我认为大多数人在提问和陈述之间并没有考虑过它们的区别。
People don't actually are not conscious when they're having conversations about how many statements they're making versus how many questions they're asking. But you found that the act of asking questions itself can have a transformative effect on a conversation. Describe that for me, Julia. What it does is it demonstrates curiosity and interest in the other person and the desire to learn about them and the desire to sort of show that you're putting in the cognitive effort. And what I mean by that is the very first paper I wrote with Francis when we were at Stanford and I was still working with Leross, was a paper about asking questions. And Lee said to us at the time, you know,
People don't actually are not conscious when they're having conversations about how many statements they're making versus how many questions they're asking. But you found that the act of asking questions itself can have a transformative effect on a conversation. Describe that for me, Julia. What it does is it demonstrates curiosity and interest in the other person and the desire to learn about them and the desire to sort of show that you're putting in the cognitive effort. And what I mean by that is the very first paper I wrote with Francis when we were at Stanford and I was still working with Leross, was a paper about asking questions. And Lee said to us at the time, you know,|||人们在交谈时实际上并没有意识到自己做了多少陈述，又问了多少问题。但你发现，提问这一行为本身会对对话产生变革性的影响。请为我描述一下，朱莉娅。它的作用是表现出对另一个人的好奇心和兴趣，以及了解他们的愿望，并表达出你正在付出认知努力的愿望。我的意思是，我和弗朗西斯在斯坦福大学时写的合著的第一篇论文，当时我还在和莱罗斯合作，是一篇关于提问的论文。李当时对我们说，你知道的，
you are not going to get good results from telling people to ask questions and conflict because people are going to ask nasty questions. They're going to say things like, what kind of idiot believes that? So, like in most things, having anything to do with psychology, Lee was right. We only started getting positive sort of effects from question asking when we specified
you are not going to get good results from telling people to ask questions and conflict because people are going to ask nasty questions. They're going to say things like, what kind of idiot believes that? So, like in most things, having anything to do with psychology, Lee was right. We only started getting positive sort of effects from question asking when we specified|||你告诉人们在冲突中提问不会得到好的结果，因为人们会问出讨厌的问题。他们会说出这样的话：“什么样的大笨蛋才会相信那个？”所以，就像大多数与心理学有关的事情一样，李是对的。直到我们明确了，我们才开始从提问中获得积极的某种效果
what kinds of questions people were allowed to ask. So, we were like, only started getting positive sort of effects from question asking when we specified what kinds of questions people were allowed to ask. So we called them elaboration questions, which are basically, you know, would you please elaborate? So you could say something like, I'm curious why you believe that, right? It's a statement, but it's doing the work of a question because what it's, you know, it's expressing curiosity.
what kinds of questions people were allowed to ask. So, we were like, only started getting positive sort of effects from question asking when we specified what kinds of questions people were allowed to ask. So we called them elaboration questions, which are basically, you know, would you please elaborate? So you could say something like, I'm curious why you believe that, right? It's a statement, but it's doing the work of a question because what it's, you know, it's expressing curiosity.|||允许人们问什么样的问题。所以，我们当时想，只有当我们明确规定允许人们问什么样的问题时，我们才开始从提问中获得积极的效果。所以我们称它们为阐述问题，这基本上是，你知道的，“请你详细阐述一下好吗？”所以你可以说这样的话：“我很想知道你为什么相信那个，对吧？”这是一个陈述句，但它起到了问题的作用，因为它表达了好奇心。
And that's similar to another paper where we got people together who are not in conflict, people who are simply trying to get to know each other and have sort of a pleasant conversation, right? So imagine, you know, being at a party with colleagues or imagine you're dating, right? What makes for a pleasant conversation? And what we found was that being asked questions, may you like your counterpart more, but it was specific questions. It was what we called follow-up questions. So if I said,
And that's similar to another paper where we got people together who are not in conflict, people who are simply trying to get to know each other and have sort of a pleasant conversation, right? So imagine, you know, being at a party with colleagues or imagine you're dating, right? What makes for a pleasant conversation? And what we found was that being asked questions, may you like your counterpart more, but it was specific questions. It was what we called follow-up questions. So if I said,|||这类似于另一篇论文，在这篇论文中，我们把没有发生冲突的人聚集在一起，这些人只是试图互相了解并进行一次愉快的对话，对吧？所以想象一下，你知道的，和同事在一个派对上，或者想象你在约会，对吧？什么样的话题才能构成愉快的对话？我们发现，被问及问题可能会让你更喜欢对方，但这是具体的问题。这就是我们所说的后续问题。所以如果我说，
where did you grow up and you say Chicago, I can't then say, where did you go on vacation? Because it's a question, but it's ignoring what you just told me. I would be much better off saying, oh, do you like the cubs? So you need a question that follows up because it demonstrates listening and interest. Some of these ideas might seem obvious. If you want to have a good conversation, listen, show interest in what the other person has to say. Demonstrate curiosity. Avoid making statements that suggest your opinion is the only opinion worth hearing.
where did you grow up and you say Chicago, I can-t then say, where did you go on vacation? Because it's a question, but it's ignoring what you just told me. I would be much better off saying, oh, do you like the cubs? So you need a question that follows up because it demonstrates listening and interest. Some of these ideas might seem obvious. If you want to have a good conversation, listen, show interest in what the other person has to say. Demonstrate curiosity. Avoid making statements that suggest your opinion is the only opinion worth hearing.|||你在哪里长大的，你说是芝加哥，我不能接着说，你去哪里度假了？因为这是一个问题，但它忽视了你刚才告诉我的话。我说“哦，你喜欢小熊队吗？”会好得多。所以你需要一个跟进的问题，因为它表现出了倾听和兴趣。其中一些想法可能看起来显而易见。如果你想进行一次愉快的谈话，请倾听，对对方要说的话表现出兴趣。表现出好奇心。避免发表暗示你的意见是唯一值得听取的意见的言论。
But knowing the right thing to do and actually doing it, are not the same thing. One day after work, Julia had the opportunity to practice conversational receptiveness with her husband. It was in a Friday evening, and Julia had spent the entire week at a mediation seminar where she got to practice the art of conversational receptiveness. This was five days, eight hours a day of nothing but mediation. And an important technique that mediators use is something they call the listening triangle, which is very conceptually related to conversational receptiveness. You ask a party in conflict a question, you listen to the answer, and then you say, well, I just heard you say, X, Y, Z, is that right? And then
But knowing the right thing to do and actually doing it, are not the same thing. One day after work, Julia had the opportunity to practice conversational receptiveness with her husband. It was in a Friday evening, and Julia had spent the entire week at a mediation seminar where she got to practice the art of conversational receptiveness. This was five days, eight hours a day of nothing but mediation. And an important technique that mediators use is something they call the listening triangle, which is very conceptually related to conversational receptiveness. You ask a party in conflict a question, you listen to the answer, and then you say, well, I just heard you say, X, Y, Z, is that right? And then|||但知道该做什么和实际去做，并不是一回事。一天下班后，朱莉娅有机会与丈夫练习对话接受度。那是一个星期五的晚上，朱莉娅整个星期都在参加一个调解研讨会，在那里她得以练习对话接受度的艺术。这是连续五天，每天八小时，除了调解别无其他。调解员使用的一项重要技术是他们所说的“倾听三角”，这在概念上与对话接受度密切相关。你向冲突中的一方提出一个问题，你听取回答，然后你说：“嗯，我刚刚听到你说了X、Y、Z，是这样吗？”然后
that starts the next round because you just asked a question. And so now you have to listen to the answer. And then they finish talking and you say, aha, so it seems like you're saying, blah, blah, blah, is that right? And then you're just supposed to do this endlessly until the person you're listening to says, yeah, yeah, yeah, you got it. Like I'm done. And I was impressed with this technique and I thought that this was really related
that starts the next round because you just asked a question. And so now you have to listen to the answer. And then they finish talking and you say, aha, so it seems like you're saying, blah, blah, blah, is that right? And then you're just supposed to do this endlessly until the person you're listening to says, yeah, yeah, yeah, you got it. Like I'm done. And I was impressed with this technique and I thought that this was really related|||这就开始了下一轮，因为你刚问了一个问题。所以现在你必须听取回答。然后他们说完后你说：“啊哈，所以看起来你是在说，巴拉巴拉，是这样吗？”然后你只需要无休止地这样做，直到你倾听的人说：“对，对，对，你懂了。就像我完了。”我对这项技术印象深刻，我认为这确实相关
to conversational receptiveness because it's all based on acknowledgement. And then, you know, the week runs out and it's Friday night. And I remember having Martini that are a kitchen bar. And my husband says the thing that he, you know, sometimes says that, you know, I'm going to be working really hard because they're these projects I want to finish and I want to get promoted.
to conversational receptiveness because it's all based on acknowledgement. And then, you know, the week runs out and it's Friday night. And I remember having Martini that are a kitchen bar. And my husband says the thing that he, you know, sometimes says that, you know, I'm going to be working really hard because they're these projects I want to finish and I want to get promoted.|||与对话接受度有关，因为这一切都建立在承认的基础上。然后，你知道的，一周结束了，已经是星期五晚上。我记得在厨房的吧台喝着马提尼。我丈夫说了一些他，你知道的，有时会说的话，你知道的，“我要非常努力地工作，因为有这些项目我想完成，我想晋升。”
And without giving it another thought, I said, you always say this. And then you never do anything about it, and then you never get credit for it. And here's what you should do instead. And he was so, so upset with me. And I was sort of surprised by how upset he was. And as I said when we're talking in the beginning of this conversation, we're not yellowers.
And without giving it another thought, I said, you always say this. And then you never do anything about it, and then you never get credit for it. And here's what you should do instead. And he was so, so upset with me. And I was sort of surprised by how upset he was. And as I said when we're talking in the beginning of this conversation, we're not yellowers.|||我没有多想，就说：“你总是这么说。然后你从来不采取任何行动，然后你永远也得不到认可。你应该这样做。”他非常、非常生我的气。我对他的生气感到有点惊讶。正如我在这次谈话开始时所说的那样，我们不是那种大吼大叫的人。
We're slow brooders. So now, you know, he is silently washing the dishes and I'm sitting there at the kitchen bar with this martini that, you know, the nice evening just kind of, you know, got destroyed. And I'm trying to understand what just happened and how we got here. And then I remember this damn class, I've been at all week. And the irony just blew my mind that I knew exactly what I should have done. And I knew it from my research and I had just spent a week practicing it on strangers. And then I was in this moment when it was perfectly applicable, and I didn't even think of doing it. And so I was surprised at how hard it was to one even bring that knowledge online in the moment. And then once it was kind of top of mind for me to really execute
We're slow brooders. So now, you know, he is silently washing the dishes and I'm sitting there at the kitchen bar with this martini that, you know, the nice evening just kind of, you know, got destroyed. And I'm trying to understand what just happened and how we got here. And then I remember this damn class, I-ve been at all week. And the irony just blew my mind that I knew exactly what I should have done. And I knew it from my research and I had just spent a week practicing it on strangers. And then I was in this moment when it was perfectly applicable, and I didn't even think of doing it. And so I was surprised at how hard it was to one even bring that knowledge online in the moment. And then once it was kind of top of mind for me to really execute|||我们是慢热型生闷气的人。所以现在，你知道的，他在默默地洗碗，而我坐在厨房的吧台上拿着这杯马提尼，你知道的，美好的夜晚就这样，你知道的，被毁了。我试图理解刚刚发生了什么以及我们是如何走到这一步的。然后我想起了这个我整周都在上的破课。那种讽刺意味让我大吃一惊：我完全知道我本该做什么。我从我的研究中知道了这一点，而且我刚刚花了一周时间在陌生人身上练习它。然后我正处于这个完全适用的时刻，我甚至没有想到要这么做。所以我很惊讶，要在当时将这些知识调动出来是多么困难。然后，一旦它成为我脑海中首要的事情去真正执行
on it. What did you do, Julia? I sat there for probably, I don't know, 15, 20 minutes wrestling with myself. And then I literally just said, you know what, let's try this again. Tell me why you think you need to work harder and longer. And then I just like shut my mouth and I listened and I asked follow up questions and I was very much not like genuinely interested, right? I was just trying to defuse a fight. And he wasn't like happy with me, but it did do the job. And he was actually not looking for my input in his career. He was looking for my support while he did what he thought needed to be done. And the entire time I'm sitting there thinking in my head, when is he going to ask me for my opinion?
on it. What did you do, Julia? I sat there for probably, I don't know, 15, 20 minutes wrestling with myself. And then I literally just said, you know what, let's try this again. Tell me why you think you need to work harder and longer. And then I just like shut my mouth and I listened and I asked follow up questions and I was very much not like genuinely interested, right? I was just trying to defuse a fight. And he wasn't like happy with me, but it did do the job. And he was actually not looking for my input in his career. He was looking for my support while he did what he thought needed to be done. And the entire time I'm sitting there thinking in my head, when is he going to ask me for my opinion?|||时，朱莉娅，你做了什么？我在那里坐了大概，我不知道，15、20分钟，跟自己作斗争。然后我真的只是说：“你知道吗，我们再试一次。告诉我为什么你觉得你需要更努力、工作更长时间。”然后我就闭上嘴听着，我问了后续问题，我非常不像是由衷地感兴趣，对吧？我只是想化解争吵。他对我也谈不上满意，但确实起到了作用。他实际上并不是在寻求我对他的职业生涯的意见。他在做他认为需要做的事情时，寻求的是我的支持。整个过程中，我坐在那里心里一直在想：他什么时候才会征求我的意见？
You know, but I'm like, nope, I said to myself, I'm not doing that anymore. And so I would just ask questions and clarify, you know, and he would talk. And then over time, he started saying, well, what do you think I should do? And I started very carefully saying, well, I might consider possibly doing XYZ, right, which is sort of hedging my claims and just sort of offering it as a suggestion not saying you need to go do X. And that's sort of been the dynamic as recognizing that it is his career. And I think me giving him that respect has led him to give me the respect of saying, hey, negotiation professor, what should I do? I mean, it's a real irony here, isn't it?
You know, but I'm like, nope, I said to myself, I'm not doing that anymore. And so I would just ask questions and clarify, you know, and he would talk. And then over time, he started saying, well, what do you think I should do? And I started very carefully saying, well, I might consider possibly doing XYZ, right, which is sort of hedging my claims and just so offering it as a suggestion not saying you need to go do X. And that's sort of been the dynamic as recognizing that it is his career. And I think me giving him that respect has led him to give me the respect of saying, hey, negotiation professor, what should I do? I mean, it's a real irony here, isn't it?|||你知道的，但我心里想：不，我对自己说，我再也不那样做了。所以我只会问问题并澄清，你知道的，然后他会说话。随着时间的推移，他开始说：“嗯，你觉得我该怎么做？”我开始非常小心地说：“嗯，我可能会考虑做X、Y、Z，对吧？”这有点像是在为我的主张留有余地，只是把它作为一种建议提出，而不是说“你需要去完成X”。这就是这种动态，认识到这是他的职业生涯。我认为我给予他这种尊重，促使他给予我尊重，说：“嘿，谈判教授，我该怎么办？”我的意思是，这真是莫大的讽刺，不是吗？
Which is the harder you push, the more he digs in his heels and stops listening, but when you stop pushing and start listening, it not only makes you less angry, but he suddenly finds it easier to seek you out and ask you for your advice. Right, and that's their findings in our research as well. So one of the studies we did with conversational receptiveness was actually to see whether being receptive might make you less persuasive, right?
Which is the harder you push, the more he digs in his heels and stops listening, but when you stop pushing and start listening, it not only makes you less angry, but he suddenly finds it easier to seek you out and ask you for your advice. Right, and that's their findings in our research as well. So one of the studies we did with conversational receptiveness was actually to see whether being receptive might make you less persuasive, right?|||也就是说，你逼得越紧，他就越固执己见，不再倾听；但当你停止施压开始倾听时，不仅能让你不那么生气，他突然也发现更容易主动来找你征求你的意见。对，这也是我们研究中的发现。因此，我们对对话接受度进行的研究之一，实际上是为了看看具有接受度是否会让你失去说服力，对吧？
So you could imagine if you're hedging your claims and showing agreement and letting the other person talk, it might be seen as like you're uncertain. And so your message actually has less impact. But instead we found the opposite. We found that when you have people who disagree on hot button issues, right? So like Black Lives Matter or what universities should do when there's an accusation of sexual assault on campus.
So you could imagine if you're hedging your claims and showing agreement and letting the other person talk, it might be seen as like you're uncertain. And so your message actually has less impact. But instead we found the opposite. We found that when you have people who disagree on hot button issues, right? So like Black Lives Matter or what universities should do when there's an accusation of sexual assault on campus.|||所以你可以想象，如果你在言论中有所保留、表现出赞同并让对方说话，这可能会被视为你很不确定。因此，你的信息实际上影响较小。但相反，我们发现了相反的结果。我们发现，当人们在热点问题上存在分歧时，对吧？比如“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter），或者当校园里出现性侵指控时大学应该怎么做。
When you train one side to use conversational receptiveness, the other side is a little more likely to actually move towards their perspective. is a little more likely to actually move towards their perspective. When we come back, barriers to conversational receptiveness and how to overcome them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Julia Minson studies how conversational receptiveness can diffuse conflicts and allow people to work together, even in the face of intractable disagreements. Julia, the behavior is associated with conversational receptiveness seemed relatively straightforward
当你训练一方去运用对话包容性时，另一方实际上更有可能朝着他们的视角转变。当我们回来时，将探讨对话包容性的障碍以及如何克服这些障碍。欢迎收听《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家朱莉娅·明森研究了对话包容性如何化解冲突，让人门能够协同合作，即便在面对不可调和的分歧时也是如此。朱莉娅，与对话包容性相关的行为似乎相对直接
and yet they can be difficult to implement as you yourself have discovered You recently had a conflict with a colleague as you were working around the clock to organize a huge academic conference. Tell me what happened We had we had a miscommunication with one of the researchers who had organized a panel for the conference. And the panel did not appear on the schedule and the researcher was upset. And we got an email back that said, let me tell you how sick and tired I am as a woman of color not being taken seriously in my role.
然而正如你亲身体验到的那样，它们可能很难付诸实践。你最近在没日没夜地筹备一个大型学术会议时，和一位同事产生了一场冲突。能告诉我发生了什么吗？我们和其中一位为会议组织了一个小组讨论的研究人员沟通失误了。那个小组讨论没有出现在日程表上，这位研究人员很不高兴。我们收到了一封回信，上面写着：让我告诉你，作为一名有色人种女性，在我的角色中没有被认真对待，我是多么的厌烦和疲惫。
And there were a couple things that made me particularly upset about this email. One was that organizing this conference is sort of nowhere in my job description. I was doing the field a favor during kind of this big time of crisis where, you know, everybody was running around trying to keep work afloat on Zoom. And so I had taken on this big task and we were rapidly approaching the conference and everybody was working really, really hard. And the other piece, of course, is the accusation that we, you know, mistreated this person because she is a woman of color
这封信中有几件事让我特别难过。第一件是，组织这个会议根本不在我的工作职责范围内。在这个大家都四处奔波、试图在Zoom上维持工作运转的大危机时期，我其实是在帮整个学术界一个忙。所以我承担了这个大任务，大会临近，每个人都在非常非常努力地工作。当然，另一部分就是指控我们，你知道的，因为她是有色人种而虐待她，
felt particularly unfounded because them being left off the program was a complete misunderstanding and innocent one of that. And so I was really upset. I'm at the grocery store, like literally in the produce style, and I get this email that's accusing me of being a racist and a sexist in one breath. And I've sort of at this point learned my lessons about conversational receptiveness, and I thought, okay, here's what I need to do. I need to get home, and I need to write this email, and I'm going to use conversational
这让我觉得特别毫无根据，因为她被漏在日程表外完全是一场误会，而且是一场无心的误会。所以我当时真的很沮丧。我正在杂货店里，字面意义上就是在蔬菜区，然后我收到了这样一封邮件，它在一气之下指控我又是个种族主义者又是个性别歧视者。此时我差不多已经吸取了关于对话心胸开阔的教训，我想，好吧，我需要做的是：我得回家，我得写这封邮件，我要运用对话
receptiveness, and I'm going to acknowledge, and I'm going to use conversational receptiveness and I'm going to acknowledge and I'm going to hedge my claims and I'm going to find areas of agreement and all the things. And the entire time I'm driving home and I'm writing these different drafts of the email in my head. And none of them sound receptive. All of them are focused on me wanting to express how incredibly upset I am that this happened
包容性，我要表示认可，我要运用对话包容性，我要进行委婉的表述，我要找出共同点，诸如此类。整个开车回家的路上，我都在脑子里起草这封邮件的不同版本。没有一个听起来是包容的。它们全神贯注于我想表达这件事对我造成了多大的打击，我是多么正确，她是多么错误，我是多么不被赏识和沮丧。
to me and how right I am and how wrong she is and how under-precied and frustrated I am. And I mean, honestly, by the time I was coming home, I was trying to think, well, maybe conversational receptiveness isn't that useful, because I can't think of any way to apply it to the situation. You know. And then I walk in the house, and my husband starts helping me unload the groceries. And so, and I'm telling him about this whole thing, and I'm, you know, fuming and saying
说实话，当我回到家的时候，我甚至在想，好吧，也许对话包容性并没有那么有用，因为我想不出任何将它应用到这种情况的方法。你知道的。然后我走进屋里，我丈夫开始帮我卸杂货。于是，我把整件事告诉了他，我当时正在气头上，说
how I need to write back, because I can't him about this whole thing. And I'm, you know, fuming and saying how I need to write back because I can't just ignore this. But also I can't think of anything particularly civil to say. And he basically just started dictating the email to me. Because, you know, of course, he listens to me talk about conversational receptiveness all day long. So he knows the entire toolkit. And he was just fabulous at it.
我必须回信，因为我不能就这么不管。但我也想不出什么特别文明的话可以说。他基本上就开始帮我口述这封邮件。因为，你知道的，他整天听我谈论对话心胸开阔。所以他懂整套方法。他在这方面简直做得太棒了。
And I mean, I literally typed out what he said and I sent it off. And within hours, I got a lovely email back that said, thank you so much for understanding. And you can relate to how hard it is to be a woman in academia. And you know, one day know, one day when the pandemic is over, we will get together and we'll get to know each other. And it was just a very nice email from a person who felt hurt. And I mean, my husband gets the credit for hearing her because in that moment, I certainly could.
我的意思是，我 literalmente 照着他说的敲出文字然后发了出去。几个小时内，我收到了一封很棒的回复邮件，上面写着：非常感谢你的理解。你能体会到身为学术界的女性有多么艰难。你知道的，等到大流行结束的那一天，我们会聚在一起，好好了解彼此。这只是一封来自一个曾经感到受伤的人的非常友好的邮件。我的意思是，我丈夫应该记首功，因为在那个时刻，我绝对做不到。
for hearing her because in that moment I certainly could. So I want to talk about the role of emotions as we're having these conflicts and disagreements. It's hard in the middle of a heated argument to put on your thinking cap and remember what the smart thing is to do. Can you just talk about how our emotions can sidetrack us from what is self-evidently the right thing to do? It's interesting emotion of course plays a huge role in conflict and in some of my work what we see is that you know the primary emotion in attitude conflict is anger It's anger and frustration sort of why don't these people get it? Why don't they see it the way I see it? So I think anger and frustration play a huge role
因为在那种情况下我绝对做不到。所以我想谈谈在这些冲突和分歧发生时情绪所扮演的角色。在激烈的争论中，要想保持理智、记住聪明的做法是很困难的。你能谈谈我们的情绪是如何让我们偏离那些显而易见正确的事情的吗？有趣的是，情绪在冲突中当然扮演着巨大的角色，在我的部分研究中，我们发现，你知道，态度冲突中的主要情绪是愤怒。这就是愤怒和沮丧，有点像：为什么这些人就是不明白？为什么他们看不到我所看到的那样？所以我认为愤怒和沮丧扮演了巨大的角色
in our inability to sort of do the right thing even when you know what the right thing is. You know, it's like there's like, I almost think of like there's a bug flying and I just have to like, smush it. You know, I can't let it keep flying around my head. And it's that impulse to put an end to the speech that you strongly disagree with. I think often gets us in trouble.
导致我们无法做出正确的事情，即便你知道什么是正确的事情。你知道，这就像，我几乎觉得就像有一只苍蝇在飞，我必须拍死它。你知道的，我不能让它一直在我头顶飞来飞去。正是这种想要终结你强烈反对的言论的冲动，我认为经常给我们带来麻烦。
One thing that you have found that poisons the water and in some ways, the letter that you received from your fellow academic, I think, speaks to this is that when we are upset in conflicts, many of us resort to using moral language. So I don't just simply say, you know, I'm upset that I've been left off the conference schedule. What explains the oversight? The person went to the additional length of basically saying, I've been left off the conference schedule because of racism and sexism. What is the effect of using moralizing language as we are debating and disagreeing with each other Julia? Yeah, so moralizing language tends to pour oil on the fire in the sense that it's very, very hard to stand in the face of that kind of
你发现的一件会破坏气氛的事情——某种程度上，你的同行学者给你的信也说明了这一点——就是在冲突中感到沮丧时，我们许多人会诉诸道德语言。所以我不仅仅是说，你知道的，我对被排除在会议日程之外感到沮丧。是什么解释了这个疏忽？这个人还进一步基本上说，我被排除在会议日程之外是因为种族主义和性别歧视。朱莉娅，我们在辩论和持不同意见时使用道德化语言，会产生什么效果？是的，所以道德化语言往往会火上浇油，因为面对这种
accusation and not react emotionally, right? Yeah, and of course, in the course of arguments, we often think that using more language is sort of a sledgehammer, right? It's sort of where we use it almost as a tactical weapon on the battlefield to basically disarm and disable our opponents, but of course our opponents are doing exactly the same to us. Right, right. And this is sort of, you know, back to naivrillism, right? We believe that we have the ultimate kind of form of evidence on our side, which is that our argument is morally superior. And so once I bring that moral perspective into this, there's no longer going to be any debate. One of the things about this four stage process that you articulated, one of the more surprising things,
指控而不做出情绪化的反应是非常非常难的，对吧？是的，当然，在争论的过程中，我们经常认为使用道德语言就像是一把大锤，对吧？我们几乎把它当作战场上的战术武器来解除对手的武装和功能，但当然我们的对手对我们也是这样做的。对，对。这就回到了朴素现实主义，对吧？我们相信我们站在终极证据的一边，那就是我们的论点在道德上是优越的。所以一旦我把这种道德视角引入其中，就不会再有任何辩论了。关于你阐述的这四个阶段的过程，其中一个比较令人惊讶的事情，
I think is that you find that when people spend time articulating their opponent's point of view, actually giving their own air time to artic articulating their opponent's point of view, actually giving their own air time to articulating what their opponent's thing, it actually makes it more likely that they are going to be heard in turn. Why do you think that it's effective to spend your own air time articulating what the other person is thinking? I think there's probably two reasons why it works. I spend a lot of time thinking about why is it
我想就是你发现，当人们花时间阐述对手的观点，甚至给自己留出空气时间去阐述对手的观点，实际上阐述对手在想什么，这反而让他们的意见更有可能反过来被别人听到。为什么你认为花出自己的时间去阐述另一个人的想法是有效的？我想这背后可能有两点原因。我花了很多时间思考为什么我们在冲突中
wearing such a rush in conflict. I think there's two reasons why we're in a rush. One is how it just feels terrible to have bad ideas out in the world and how we just want to back them down. The other is that most of these conversations are very unpleasant. You want to get back them down. The other is that most of these conversations are very unpleasant. And so you want to get out of there and you expect that your partner wants to get out of there. And so there's this feeling of like, if I don't say it, then I'm never going to have a chance to say
会如此匆忙。我认为我们匆忙有两个原因。一是带着不好的想法在世界上游荡感觉太糟糕了，我们只想把它们驳倒。另一个是，其中大部分对话都非常令人不快。你只想把它们驳倒。另一个是，大部分这类对话都非常令人不快。所以你想离开那里，而且你预料你的对话伙伴也想离开那里。因此会有这样一种感觉：如果我现在不说，我就永远没有机会说了
it because this is going to be, you know, a short and furious conversation. I think acknowledging your counterparts counterparts point of view and really listening to them and asking them lots of questions, triggers two things. One, it triggers reciprocity, right? So reciprocity is one of the most powerful social forces we've ever studied. And if I listen to you patiently and at length, and then I start talking, you're gonna feel like a real jerk interrupting me. And now that I have given you my time
因为这将是一场短暂而激烈的对话。我认为承认对方的观点并真正倾听他们、向他们询问大量问题，会触发两件事。第一，它会触发互惠心理，对吧？因此，互惠是我们研究过的最强大的社会力量之一。如果我耐心且长时间地听你倾听，然后我才开始说话，你会觉得打断我的人简直是个混蛋。既然我已经把时间给了你
and let you, my ear, you now have to do the same. And I think the second thing it triggers is, it makes the conversation much less unpleasant and therefore that feeling of urgency disappears. We go from this, like how fast can I say my piece because this is all about to explode, to let's have a long, thoughtful, drawn-out conversation about this that just has a very different pace to it. In studying conversational receptiveness, you drew a distinction between actually displaying
并听取了你的意见，你现在也必须这样做。我认为它触发的第二件事是，它使对话变得不那么令人愉快，因此那种紧迫感消失了。我们从“因为这一切都快要爆发了，我得用多快的速度发表我的意见”转变为“让我们就此展开一次长期的、深思熟虑的、冗长的对话，让对话呈现出完全不同的节奏”。在研究对话包容性时，你区分了实际表现出
conversational receptiveness as in actually feeling it, you know, what's going on inside your head, and actually demonstrating it on the outside, regardless of whether you actually feel that we are not. So in the email that you composed to your fellow academic, presumably at the point at which you hit send, given that your husband composed the email for you, you didn't actually feel everything that you said in the email. And yet it had the effect of having the other person say, okay, this person is really listening to me. What are you recommending here? Are you recommending that we actually try to be more empathetic and open to other people or that we simply just demonstrate that we're doing those things? You know, I wish the world was a place where people in conflict could feel empathetic and open and then act on that empathy in a way that sort of transparent and recognizable to their counterparts.
对话包容性（就像真正感受到它一样，你知道，你脑子里在想什么）和在表面上展示它，而不管你实际上是否真的有这种感觉。所以在你写给同行学者的那封电子邮件中，据推测，在你按下发送键的那一刻，鉴于这封邮件是你丈夫为你代笔的，你其实并没有完全感受到邮件中所说的每一句话。然而它却起到了让对方说“好吧，这个人真的在听我说话”的效果。你在这里推荐什么？你建议我们真的试着更有同理心并对他人保持开放，还是简单地展示我们在做这些事情？你知道，我希望世界是一个这样的地方：身处冲突中的人们可以感受到同理心和包容，然后以一种对他们的谈话对象透明且可识别的方式根据这种同理心采取行动。
But I don't think that's how humans work. I think conversation or receptiveness is a lot like the other types of aspirations we have that sometimes we live up to and sometimes we fail to live up to. Right. So we have lots of Right, so we have lots of goals. I want to exercise more often. I want to spend less time on Twitter. You know, I want to, you know, call my mom like all the things that you know you want to do, but for various reasons, you fail to live up to. And I think conversational receptiveness is like that.
但我不认为人类是这样运作的。我认为对话包容性很像我们拥有的其他类型的抱负，有时我们能做到，有时我们做不到。对。所以我们有许多的对，所以我们有很多目标。我想更经常地锻炼。我想减少刷Twitter的时间。你知道，我想，你知道，像所有你知道你想做的事情一样打电话给我妈妈，但由于各种原因，你没有做到。我认为对话包容性就是这样的。
It's that you aren't as receptive as you aspire to be. And so in that moment, I think faking it is perfectly fine. Right? You get there, however you get there, because it leads to a better outcome. You know, if you think back to my example, right? I didn't write the email that the screaming voice in my head was writing. I knew that that was not the kind of person I wanted to be in the situation. And so I think conversational receptiveness is a toolkit to kind of help people live
就是你没有你所渴望的那样具有包容性。所以在那个时刻，我认为假装它是完全可以接受的。对吧？你无论如何都能达到那个目的，因为这会带来更好的结果。你知道，如果你回想我的例子，对吧？我并没有写下我脑海中那个尖叫的声音正在写的邮件。我知道那不是我想在这种情况下成为的那种人。所以我认为对话包容性是一个工具包，可以帮助人们生活
up to their best selves even when in the emotional moment, they can't quite do it like they can't improvise their way there. Or they can't do it authentically if you will. Right right right but the diffused fight is better than the undiffused fight. Conversational receptiveness is not a magic bullet. Not everyone you listen to carefully is going to come around to your point of view. In her own life, Julia has realized that what conversational receptiveness really allows her to do is to keep an intractable conflict in one domain from derailing an entire relationship. Yeah, I think part of what happens is people are so focused on persuading the other side that they don't think about laying the groundwork for the next conversation. Right? Every conversation is just the lead up to the future conversation. And so what can you do now to make the next one better,
达到他们最好的自我，即使在情绪激动的时刻，他们无法完全做到这一点，就像他们无法即兴发挥到那个地步一样。或者换句话说，他们无法真实地做到这一点。对对对，但是化解了的争吵总比没有化解的争吵要好。对话包容性不是灵丹妙药。并不是你仔细倾听的每个人都会转而支持你的观点。在她的生活中，朱莉娅意识到，对话包容性真正让她能够做到的是，防止一个领域的不可调和的冲突破坏整个关系。是的，我想部分发生的情况是，人们太专注于说服对方，以至于他们没有考虑为下一次对话打下基础。对吧？每一次对话都只是通往未来对话的铺垫。所以你现在能做些什么来让下一次更好呢，
kinder, more informative, more harmonious, you know, all of those things. And then, you know, persuasion may or may not happen somewhere along the way, but can we focus on the next conversation? focus on the next conversation. Julia Minson is a psychologist at Harvard University. Julia, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
更友好、信息更丰富、更和谐，你知道，所有这些事情。然后，你知道，说服可能会也可能不会在某个时候发生，但我们能专注于下一次对话吗？专注于下一次对话。朱莉娅·明森是哈佛大学的心理学家。朱莉娅，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏大脑》。我的荣幸。《隐藏大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For our unsung hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. Today's unsung hero is brought to you by OnStar. OnStar advisors are now with you everywhere, on the app, in your car, and at home.
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏大脑》的执行主编。对于我们的无名英雄环节，我们把话筒交给你，我们的听众。今天的无名英雄由OnStar赞助。OnStar顾问现在无处不在，在应用程序里，在你的车里，还有在家中。
OnStar. Be safe out there. Our story comes from Rich Addison. So when I was young, I was very shy. I was an only child who was pretty comfortable talking to adults, but I never had any brothers and sisters to practice on. So I wasn't very good at kind of mixing it up with the other kids. And I remember being very anxious about going to school.
OnStar。祝你出行平安。我们的故事来自里奇·埃迪森。所以当我年轻的时候，我非常害羞。我是个独生子女，和成年人聊天时挺自在的，但我从来没有兄弟姐妹可以用来练习。所以我在和别的孩子打成一片方面不是很在行。我记得对去学校感到非常焦虑。
And on Sunday nights, I would not be able to sleep just worrying about what would happen with the other kids. So now, flash forward a few years, and I'm in high school. And I realized that I had to be different, that I couldn't keep being so shy. So I went about developing a quick wit and a sense of humor that would keep other kids off balance. So I wouldn't have to feel powerless.
在周日的晚上，我经常会因为担心其他孩子会发生什么而无法入睡。所以现在，快进几年，我上了高中。我意识到我必须改变，我不能一直这么害羞。所以我开始培养机智的谈吐和幽默感，这能让其他孩子们保持一种不稳定的平衡。这样我就不用感到无能为力了。
You know how sometimes people say the best defense is a good offense. Well, that was what I was doing. But the sense of humor I developed was kind of biting and kind of critical. So now my hero is about to come into the story. And this was my friend Holly. One day Holly and I were talking and she said to me, you know, rich, sometimes you really hurt people's feelings. And at first, I was just shocked. I said to myself, that can't be true. I was entertaining, I made people laugh,
你知道有时人们会说最好的防御就是好的进攻。好吧，我当时就是这么做的。但我培养出的幽默感有点带刺，也有点爱批评人。现在我的朋友要出场了，这就是我的故事。这就是我的朋友霍莉。有一天，我和霍莉在聊天，她对我说，你知道的，里奇，有时你真的会伤害别人的感情。起初，我非常震惊。我对自己说，那不可能是真的。我很会逗人开心，我让人发笑，
I liked people, these were my friends, I didn't wanna to hurt them. I couldn't be hurting them. But I kept thinking about what Holly said and I kept turning it over in my mind. And eventually I realized that she was absolutely right. And I started paying attention to how my humor was affecting other people. And I changed it. It didn't happen immediately, it didn't happen overnight, but I changed and I wanted to be more compassionate towards people. And I wanted to have a different kind of relationship
我喜欢人们，这些都是我的朋友，我不想伤害他们。我不可能在伤害他们。但我一直在思考霍莉的话，并在脑海里反复琢磨。最终我意识到她是绝对正确的。我开始关注我的幽默是如何影响其他人的。我改变了。它没有立即发生，也没有在一夜之间发生，但我改变了，我希望对人们更加富有同情心。我希望能建立起一种不同类型的关系
with them than always keeping them off balance. So after I went on to become a clinical psychologist and in my role, I try to help other people have generous interpretations about themselves and others. And I've also made a career out of training physicians to do that. And I really am so grateful that I made that shift in my life. And I really owe it to Holly. And I think back to that time, so many years ago,
而不是总是让他们处于不稳定的平衡中。所以后来我成为了一名临床心理学家，在我的角色中，我努力帮助其他人对自己和他人抱有宽容的解释。我也把培训医生这样做作为我的职业。我真的很感激我在生活中做出了那个转变。我真的要把它归功于霍莉。我想起多年前的那个时刻，
and when she cared enough to say something to me, something that probably wasn't easy to say, but it was something that changed the direction of my life in a very significant and very gratifying way. So, thank you, Holly. You're my unsung hero. Rich Addison lives in Santa Rosa, California. Recently, he was able to reconnect with Holly and tell her how much her comment has meant to him some 50 years later. This segment was brought to you by OnStar. OnStar believes everyone has the right to feel
当她足够在乎而对我说些什么的时候，有些话可能并不容易说出口，但它却以一种非常显著且非常令人欣慰的方式改变了我的人生方向。所以，谢谢你，霍莉。你是我心中的无名英雄。里奇·埃迪森住在加利福尼亚州圣罗莎。最近，他得以与霍莉重新取得联系，并在大约50年后告诉她，她的评论对他意味着多么重大的意义。本环节由OnStar赞助。OnStar坚信每个人都有权利感到
safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help, not only in the car but wherever you are, on your phone, in your car and at home. OnStar, be safe out there. If you like this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if episodes like this help you live a better life, if they improve the quality of your relationships, please do your part to help us make more shows like this. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
在任何地方都是安全的。这就是为什么他们的紧急顾问现在可以随时提供帮助，不仅在车里，无论你在哪里，在你的手机上、在你的车里和家里。OnStar，祝你出行平安。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。访问support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一次，如果像这样的节目能帮你过上更好的生活，如果它们改善了你的人际关系质量，请尽你的一份力量来帮助我们制作更多这样的节目。访问support.hiddenbrain.org。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。